nationaux de 1893 suffrages 48 00 alain
suguenot a le triomphe modeste +2 48%
avec cinq listes présentes mais moins de
43 % de taux de participation dans un
contexte où plane un doute sur
l'organisation du second tour dimanche
prochain et vaudoises et des beaunois
continue à me faire confiance
on a échoué à 93 voix pour passer au
premier tour ce qui a effectivement un
beau score donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle ben y aura un deuxième tour
dimanche prochain les cordes et varius
j'espère dans quelques semaines sera je
l'espère une histoire ancienne empêche
que démocratie elle subsiste les
élections municipales au contraire on le
voit bien c'est ce désir de proximité je
pense qu'on sortira d'autant plus de ces
crises
si des élections ont lieu et que s'il y
a des élus municipaux qui sont
l'alignement pour assumer les
responsabilités comme on l'a fait
aujourd'hui d'horizon des élections eric
mono le candidat soutenu par la
république en marche arrive second avec
seulement 23 % des suffrages
s'il veut peser au second tour ils
doivent se tourner vers carole bernard
la candidate de la gauche
nous on discute pas avec le front
national un sens de toute manière ça
c'est donc ça c'est sûr donc il reste
que la liste de carole bernard avec
laquelle on va rencontrer dans la nuit
s'ils veulent nous rencontrer
c'est pas faux si leur poser la question
pour l'instant je ne sais pas je ne vais
pas décider seul
je travaille avec une équipe depuis des
mois et donc nous allons en discuter en
équipe ce soir
mais vous ne vous maintenez pas coûte
que coûte vous est ouverte on discute on
est ouverts à une discussion à beaune la
salle de la mairie se vide rapidement
après les résultats
les candidats ont tous annulé la soirée
initialement prévue avec leurs militants